okay in this video we're going to talk
about the adrenal there are other videos
that will show you all the different
symptoms so I'm not going to cover that
but just I'm going to cover some
important things and then what to do if
you have an adrenal issue first of all
you shouldn't you need to know that the
adrenal gland adapts the body to all
stress states it prepares the body and
it adapts it for a stress State the
problem is all stress accumulates in the
body even from birth so it's stuck there
and what we have to do is we have to
extract all the body stress because it's
still there even the injury on your head
when you were 10 all that stuff is still
there it's almost as if your adrenals
are reacting now in present time to old
stuff you have too many applications on
your desktop computer that are running
in the past that sucks energy from the
adrenal in present time making the
adrenal not function correctly the
adrenal gland is unique and it has an
outside and inside the outside is gland
the inside is all nerve tissue so the
nerves it's called the flatter fight
like adrenaline type things I don't want
going to give you a lot on that right
now but the point is you need to know
that they're there this is what the hub
of stress occurs it's right on top of
the kidney
you have the pituitary that controls on
a feedback circuit back and forth there
are two acupressure techniques that
you're going to learn but you're going
to need help on one of them because
there's something advanced I'm going to
show you that will really help
chill out those adrenals and I'll
explain exactly how to do it now what
you have to do is there's several key
things that we recommend in addition to
the acupressure the acupressure extracts
the stress but there's some nutritional
things be won by them be won
when you the more stress you experience
the more about mb1 you deplete the best
source of b1 is in nutritional yeast
you can get from the healthiest or try
to find the one that is non fortified
okay and this will really help counter
nervous tension and stress in your body
the way you know you're deficient in b1
is you know this lot is built up stress
and you just want to explode but my
adrenal day formula has natural b1 in it
because it's hard to find so the deep
the adrenal day when people take it they
just feel really calm that's because of
one of the things that has which is b1
okay now the other thing is potassium
now even if you have a blood test it's
not going to show up because 98% of all
your potassium is inside this cell not
on your blood so your cells have to be
severely depleted before even shows up
on a blood test but potassium the main
function potassium is to help support
the nervous system and when you don't
have enough potassium your your anxiety
of stress you have nerve issues it
affects the heart it's an electrolyte
that's very important into calming the
body and helping things like restless
leg syndrome and so the way you get that
is from the big salads you need you ever
see those big plastic things a salad
that are like these squares that's so
that's probably eight ounces that's how
much salad you need that's eight cups
per day you one ounce per per cup so you
need to start having more salads or
vegetables to get the potassium in your
body not a banana is 300 milligrams you
need 4700 so forget the fruit okay so
adrenal fatigue formula that's a we have
we have a product that's called adrenal
fatigue formula the new name is called
adrenal night formula it's the same
formula so you can take one before bed
that has certain nutrients to put you at
in a relaxed state so you can actually
go to sleep at night so we recommend
that and then drean all day during the
day because it has the natural bees to
actually extract it a lot of other
things too to help extract stress as far
as the exercise goes we recommend low
intensity things you can do yo
but walking is the best get out there
and walk as long as you can because that
really will you need low intensity lots
of breathing to be able to pull out the
stress so this is the protocol for
adrenal on the next part we're going to
show you how to do acupressure on the
adrenals and then there's a last part
we'll show you some advanced things to
do with the adrenal as well but you're
going to need someone else to do that on
you okay I hope this helped